alors jean d'ormesson quand je vais
inviter dans bad minuit on m'a dit
pourquoi m'inviter vous oui vous dire
pourquoi parce que vous respirez la
gaieté vous avez des yeux qui pétillent
quel choc la seule chose que je pourrais
vous reprocher ses dettes vous êtes
parent avec peletier de saint-fargeau
quand même qui est un régicide
awek était très fier je ne renie rien à
part quand justement je lui ai demandé
ce que faisait part aux varois de
quelqu'un qui a voté la mort 2016 que
lui aurait été assassinée quelques jours
il a été assassiné ou au palais royal à
peu près là où elles resteront véfour
maintenant dans un restaurant qui
s'appelait février si je me rappelle
bien
il ya eu il a une
malchance il est tombé sur un gars du
roi il s'appelait parisse et le barde du
roi évidemment elle avait rencontré
plusieurs fois à versailles puisque il
est tête
l'entourage de louis saez et malgré ça
puisqu'il était conventionnelle et qu'il
était aussi un âne ou dans l'espoir
d'arrêter la mort au nom je pense que la
vente et la mort du roi
bon moi je ne pense pas que j'aurais
voté la mort du roi et surtout pas voté
la mort de la reine les vingt années de
règne de 2016 ont été l'apogée de la
france savait écouter
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez est-ce
que lisez mon confrère capssom à
l'académie dax haute disait supposons
que louis saez soit mort en 1884 en 1984
si c est bien la révolution aurait eu
lieu tout de même et tous les historiens
il irait quel malheur qu'il soit mort si
lui avait vécu et diarrhée bien bas la
révolution n'aurait pas eu lieu où elle
se serait bien passé alors vous voyez je
crois que c'est tout à fait vrai vous ne
pensez pas ces rois libéral
tout à fait sous son règne que des
droits de l'homme ont été proclamés vous
ne pensez pas vous faites partie d'une
espèce en voie de disparition tiers des
gens qui travaillent beaucoup mais qui
donne toujours comme ça l'impression
d'une certaine facilité
2 toujours à l'aise je vous ai vus
arriver tout à l'heure vous êtes à
l'aise vous entretenez avec tout le
monde
vous êtes star dans les dîners en ville
parce que vous êtes briand est cultivée
je pensais pas que les gens comme vous
il y en a de moins en moins capables
evolia je travaille beaucoup je suis sur
mon travail et j'ai longtemps fait
croire que je ne travaillais pas
beaucoup maintenant c'est presque
difficile de faire croire que je ne
travaille pas beaucoup parce qu'on ne
voit plus beaucoup d'envié envie ni dans
les cocktails
parce que je travaille et le week-end le
samedi ou dimanche évidemment je
travaille je suis pas si les résultats
sont à la hauteur du travail mais en
tout cas je travaille
il fera un petit reproche donc dire que
louis pauwels il fait delhi - bien que
vous mais ces articles sont pas mal
écrit mais comment ils sont très très
très très bien ces artistes outre les
miens sont pas bien écrit je trouve que
c'est un peu moins bien que vos livres
vous donner autant de mal que lui pour
faire vos papiers du figaro magazine
je ne sais pas en tout cas c'est vrai
que j'ai fait de mon mieux
ouais mais c'est vrai que j'attache plus
important support tony bruit trouver vos
articles quand on lui en parle et 10
mois chaque semaine je fais une page de
livre dans le figaro magazine et c'est
vrai alors que vous bon sang c'est un
peu plus de d'accord idiot c'est
travailler un peu plus les affaires doit
faire un effort par là tu peux me
permettre
vous avez raison je tâcherai pierre des
corps vous êtes super brillant mais nul
n'en disconvient mais on se demande
finalement cela de votre brillante vd
des convictions profondes pas être
catholiques du sud catholique
le pape a condamné l'apartheid vous le
savez le tacle est ce que vous faites
entre la situation de l'afrique dessus
je suis tout à fait contre l'apartheid
qu'est ce que vous faites quand on
apporte alors je vous dis à d'abord j'ai
joué aussi bien que ça commençait à peu
trop bien joli ça va maintenant
vous avez tout à fait raison
alors je dois vous dire que quand j'ai
été nommé directeur du figaro est une
des acteurs et yao très noir on a fait
un petit discours en trois points où il
ya dix d'abord pardonnez moi il est
d'abord il est très intelligent voter
pour lui deuxièmement il est d'une
ignorance encyclopédie tapas tard on lui
a toujours voté pour lui et
troisièmement et c'est ce que j'ai dit
il ya des convictions très ferme mais
extrêmement tac c'est très commode voter
pour lui j'ai été alors c'est vrai que
je ne suis pas militant je ne suis pas
un militant
je suis un militant pour certaines
causes que je crois je pense qu'il est
juste par exemple pour la majorité
actuelle que contre le contre
l'apartheid d'accord vous pouvez pas
venir si on fait des papiers
d'abord j'ai d'abord
j'ai des liens avec l'unesco un endroit
les nations unies qui ont condamné le
plus fermement l'appart n
donc je ne suis pas suspect de défendre
l'apartheid ensuite je crois qu'il ya un
peu d'hypocrisie dans les affaires
l'apartheid si on veut rompre avec les
régimes dont on ne partage pas les
opinions et je ne partage pas l'opinion
régnant en afrique du sud
je ne partage pas non plus celle ci
règne en russie
et si on rompt avec l'afrique du sud
ce que je peux pas pas bien je ne lance
pas là dedans pour contre avec l'iran et
pourront qui nous a fait plus de mal
[Musique]
avec le fait je me suis prononcé trenet
très vivement contre pinochet je ne suis
pas pour qu'ils achètent je ne suis pas
pour l'afrique du sud je ne suis pas
pour le région de soviétiques et que je
vive avec eux
et je trouve que ce qui s'est passé ces
jours ci c'est à dire le refus des
polonais du référendum
george hotz qui est quelque chose
stupéfiants car jal de ce qui leur est
dit est ce que vous approuvez les
réformes démocratiques
est-ce que vous approuvez que je vous
donne un peu plus de liberté et les
polonais ont répondu non c'est un peu
pareil son racisme ne pas condamner le
racisme
qu'est ce qui nous fait contre le refus
tout à fait contre le racisme vous
faites quoi
je sais quoi parce que chateaubriand lui
il avait la duchesse de berry se désole
du mal attendez les à prague je vais
vous dire ce que je fais pour le figaro
magazine où vous approuvez beaucoup
mon ami pour elle ce que nous avons
aussi beaucoup et bien je suis un des
rares à m élevé avec autant de force
contre le pen ben si vous trouvez que
c'est pas quelque chose mais c'est
l'heure de sel et contre le pen dans
leur magazine
et bien maintenant tout le monde le fait
mais j'ai même reçu pas mal de l'aide de
lecteurs trouvant que je t'ai dans le
figaro magazine
bien beau vous tombez amoureux d'une
petite bird une beurette moi oui si elle
ne plaisait oui sans aucun doute
dans l'ombre le problème je crois aussi
que je les écris et que j'ai écrit que
si ma fille tombée amoureuse d'un noir
et ben je serais tout à fait chanter
qu'elle dépose à condition naturellement
qu'ils tiennent président de la
république du soir frank sinatra
ben parce qu'il faut pas être vous aider
leurs entreprises il a vous avez à les
plans aussi les nuages alors voilà il
faut prendre ce qu'il ya de mieux
partout et naturellement il fait l'ombre
de différence entre un blanc ajourné
aloi je fais quand même une différence
entre un journée à blanche quand les
autres sont plus intelligents pardonnez
moi d'être raciste mais je crains tu les
jaunes soit plus intelligent qui est
blanc vous avez écrit quelque chose moi
qui m'a beaucoup touché parce que je
pensais un peu la même chose ça injuste
si un jour je me retrouve en prison ce
sera génial parce que moi je pourrais
écrire des livres
oui à condition naturellement comme on
traite bien qu'on m'envoie on en voit
comment vous l'appelez une beurette vous
voulez un petit peu raide comme en voit
une beurette et concrètes bien j'ai un
bon lit que j'ai trois manger peu mais à
la laisse des gens étaient enchantés dix
ans à la bastide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez thierry omd toujours chantal
mckee et tétouan mais moi j'ai un scoop
sur monsieur d'un maçon oui il est fan
de baffie ah bon il adore tout ce que
fait baffie titre sa fin subtil jamais
grossier ne va pas bien profond même nom
il adore ça il vous le dira pas aller
voter mais de regarder le nom messi sera
tu n'es pas il ferait son d'ormesson
chaud mais il fera tient à nom comme ça
ça se retient seulement j'aurais
peut-être dû me retenir aussi et non je
pense
chantal ladesou
alors
aussi quand même vous avez été un
intello très médiatique non parce que
finalement chose que je savais pas du
tout j'ai appris que j'avais participé
aux grosses têtes c'est vrai absolument
je crois pas c'était à travers d'une
journée avant l'académie française après
aussi aulnoye oui absolument
vous avez fait beaucoup de télé quand
même non oui enfin vous ai fait beaucoup
journalisme si vous en faites encore
beaucoup et vous êtes un peu laissé vous
le regrettez ça vous êtes et c'est un
peu happé par l'actualité quoi un peu
perdu un peu de temps par rapport à vos
activités d'écrivain non oui oui oui un
peu vous connaissez la phrase de gide
j'appelle une journalisme ce qui sera
moins intéressant demain qu'aujourd'hui
c'est sa chance à oui c'est pas tant
ouais ça je me répète ça souvent oui et
je dois vous dire que paul morand se
jetaient toujours sur moi
ils avaient été très choqués par une
france que veut le premier livre et il
se serait sûrement bien surtout pas de
pornographie et surtout pas de gens là
dix ans alors que lui évidemment faisait
du journalisme mais il les mettait dans
ses murs il a écrit des phrases très
peur mais politiquement absolument les
coup-francs sa douche
il a écrit aussi je déteste écrire mais
j'adore avoir écrit ce vrai ouais là
didon baffie alors si alors qu'elle est
dernier parmi nous qui a fait pivot
c'est moins le dernier qui est pivot aux
délégués alors y'a pas photo j'ai bien
tranchées surtout la spécialité
[Musique]
bien grand talent tard maintenant
maintenant vous le panier c'est ce que
je lui ai dit ça leur est difficile
voire prêt mais attention pas à rejeter
à tort que puis j'ai eu un grand
désavantage à la télé c'est que je vous
ai vu aussi accueilli à queue puis vous
appris baffie pas pour apostrophe mais
pour bouillon oui il a fait pire ont
quand même il a fait bouillir
ouais c'est dégueulasse vous avez dit je
méprise les honneurs oui c'est pour ça
que j'ai cueilli au passage
oui parce que la seule façon de vraiment
les mépriser ces d avoir une chance on
est toujours un peu suspect placé pour
répondre à ma fille qui est bien c'est
costaud la gueule de monsieur vertige
récitation de l'excitation c'est
l'horrible passion d'envié ce qu'on est
pris à la turbie de tonnes et variées
vous vire à 2 qui sait de qui c'est luis
mariano
j'ai connu toutes les formes de
déchéance y compris le succès de qui
alors dit son nom si aaron il ya deux
drames dans l'existence réussir sa vie
et l'a ratée 7 qui visitent entre cioran
et moi non oscar wilde rôle a eu quand
même tant va la cruche à l'eau
[Rires]
en fait pourquoi vous avez passé autant
de temps comme ça essayer d'acquérir le
pouvoir aux jeux jamais sylla qui ne
pouvoir jamais ce que je peux me
reprocher est ce qu'on peut me reprocher
c'est d'avoir essayé d'acquérir une
certaine notoriété
et si vous voulez me faire dire ce que
je regrette c'est ça j'ai sûrement eu
envie et je trouve ça aujourd'hui tout à
fait méprisable d'être connu j'ai
sûrement aimé ça ça j'aime ça je n'ai
jamais aimé ne pouvoir jamais voulu
avoir le pouvoir
j'ai toujours trouvé le pouvoir tout à
fait médiocre et gamme bio j'ai le
figaro pendant un moment ce n'est pas le
pouvoir ça et bouteilles franchement
d'abord oui d'abord c'est le pouvoir
d'abord je n'ai jamais cherché en bluff
est évidemment je ne vais pas écartée il
faut dire que dès que je peux tirer je
me suis tiré et
c'était c'était très tentant c'était
très amusant il faut avoir craché dessus
vent c'est un beau temps chaud vous avez
perdu beaucoup de temps et les
mentalités aussi non pour train
je me souviens d'un article vous disiez
je fais plus de dîners en ville
cette année j'en ai fait quatre et ont
été le 19 janvier 4 dinars si c'est vrai
parce que maintenant les gens disent ça
on voit partout à jouets lavefve norma
pernaut a évidemment très très très peu
de choses sur très peu les femmes nous
ont fait perdre du temps aussi on pas se
perdre du temps il monte au nez du leur
et warrants subie à l'amour il ya les
livres il y à rien cette équipe
montherlant vous reconnaîtrez pour
parler des femmes c'est pas le mieux
placé montherlant quand même nom mais il
en parle très bien et je trouve que ça
s'est très très bien et vous avez dit si
j'avais été une femme j'aurais mener les
hommes en bourrique
c'est quoi vous regrettez pas avoir été
une garce non c'est parce que je pense
que
c'est parce que je pense que je pense
que un des traits que je que j'engage
chez moi c'est de ce désir de plaire
j'ai sûrement un diseur de plaine que
comme et vous plaisir non non mais vous
voyez sa peine je vais essayer de faire
tout ce que je pouvoir pour le séduire
mais ça va rater cette allocation
séduire alors alors je pense que si
j'avais été une femme
sa mort est formidablement amusé de
faire marcher des hommes si on vous
avait dit le maillage enfin en prenant
les précautions oratoires vis-à-vis de
votre femme bien sûr le maillage est
quelque chose d'abominable et la
révolution française avait bien fait de
de bannir les voeux perpétuels
révolution à manille et veut pas
respectueux elle est en effet le mariage
et le dernier voeux perpétuels fosses
abominable je mets ma femme tout à fait
en dehors qui a eu la bonté de me
supporter pendant si longtemps et qui
étaient en dehors qu'il faut la mettre
mais le mariage sauf ça je trouve ça une
épreuve redoutable ou savez c'est tout à
fait clair parce que le mariage il y a
chantant on se mariait déjà un peu vieux
avec des jeunes femmes très jeunes et
puis qu'est ce qu'on faisait au mouret
ouais mais l'idée le passé simple oui
c'est ça c'est maintenant vie trop vieux
on se marie à 18 ans et on vit jusqu'à
90 ans
pour vous êtes entrevoir des acteurs
attendent et inclusion enfin franchement
ressortent chez lattès donc trois romans
vais publier qui ressorte dans le même
temps le volume c'est combien de pages
on sent 63 ou 65 12 quelque chose comme
200 par le vent du soir tous les autres
on s'en fout et le bonheur à san miniato
le vent du soir les gens diraient qu'il
a chez mickey sur les relations devaient
parler de ces trois romans il y avait
quoi que ça feuilleton planétaire où le
je dirais que c'est un peu c'est un
feuilleton
oui c'est un roman c'est un roman
feuilleton tarn en feuilleton qui ont
lieu de se passer ça à paris se passe
dans le monde entier où vous savez ce
que ce qui s'est passé depuis depuis 100
ans et que on se déplace une des choses
qui qui se fait ses courses de places
est une des choses qui m'amusent et dans
ce livre c'était de faire un roman qui
se passe en chine au brésil en amérique
pologne et quand on se balade un peu
partout je vais ensuite à un feuilleton
qui se passe partout et c'est une des
histoires d'amour d'un feuilleton quoi
alors il ya quatre seul agenda frère ça
on va essayer de le raconter parce que
non je l'histoire de quatre soeurs et
deux frères et j'ai toujours été
fascinée non seulement parlent
l'unification du monde mais pas les
histoires de seul j'aime beaucoup les
soeurs je trouve que c'est très joli les
histoires de soeur c'est toujours
amusant parce que il ya une rivalité
entre elles une émulation elles sont
semblables sont différentes
il ya dans l'histoire plein d'histoires
deux soeurs très amusante
il ya eu et fait un effort massif sans
contre hitler churchill staline on en
croise les grands de ce monde en face
alors ce qui se passe n'est ce pas dans
un roman c'est que contrairement à ce
qu'on croit contrairement à ce que
croient bastille qui est plus là je peux
l'attaqué puisqu'il est plus large
c'est que dans un roman ça ne compte pas
vos dans un roman en lançant que vous à
une course
[Applaudissements]
et les vins
les barbares sont aux portes de la ville
dans un roman ça ne consiste pas à
inventer des choses extraordinaires et
il faut plutôt diminuer les choses de la
vie pour essayer de faire des choses
qu'ils soient vrais semble à haut risque
de consacrer moins de temps encore avec
les tiers à qui le relance là
chaque mois le temps à l'écriture vous
êtes engagé donc vos produits brevetés
nick l'année dernière est ce que vous
engageriez pour la somalie écoutez bien
sûr il ya des causes innombrables pour
lesquelles il faut se battre et
évidemment longue à dubrovnik parce que
c'est plus beau graphiquement c'est vrai
qu'on me l'a reproché d'ailleurs douves
revenus que ça m'a un peu bousculée
parce que c'est une très belle ville que
si versailles ou venise ou ou chartres
était menacé ça vous et se sont fait de
choses mais naturellement les gens qui
désirent un petit peu serait amoureux
amoureux il ya ça aussi mais évidemment
les gens qui se font tuer à osijek coup
a vu qu'au bar ou à sarajevo qui est
moins beau que double revenu que c'est
exactement la même chose
et évidemment il ya quarante cause dans
le monde loue ou auxquelles on pourrait
se consacrer il ya un côté quelquefois
un peu ridicule il ya un côté génocide
et tourisme à celui
les recevoir maintenant est un trésor
vivant une espèce en voie de disparition
un homme du xviiie siècle d'une culture
incroyable qui manie aussi bien la
langue parlée que la langue écrite voici
jean d'ormesson
bonsoir
c'est pas du sadisme nous avons remis
tous les deux à côté j'ai l'air un peu
plus grand que vous mais bon ça soit
moins quand on est assis ça soit plus
qu'un satellite et si vous avez bien mal
on est très heureuse de la part troublée
non vas-y tout à l'heure un petit peu
quand même on m'a non mais on est très
contents de vous avoir surtout tout à
l'heure on a dit beaucoup de bien de
vous on a dit que j'étais intelligent
tout le temps parce que nous on disait
qu'avec des moments où j'étais quand
même un peu bête quoi mais vous tout le
temps obligé que des trucs intelligents
on va voir ça alors est ce que vous êtes
dans votre phase bardot dans votre phase
garbo alors j'explique à vos amis
téléspectateurs gendarmes le sens il ya
deux positions c'est soit il est dans sa
phase bardot thierry ce mantra la
télévision soit une surface garbo série
reste planqué chez lui là vous êtes
plutôt en ce moment je vous ai vu sur
une autre chaîne audio vous n'êtes plus
dans votre choix de bardos non limite
limite à c'est bientôt la fin du bardo
vous connaissez saisie représentant de
commercy lexomil l'émission guette linda
hardy qui se ronge les ongles parce
qu'elle connaît pas le lexomil et michel
noir qui est beaucoup plus marrant
depuis qu'il a arrêté la politique a
alors jean d'ormesson vous avez déclaré
parce que vous pouvez déclarer ces
cioran mais vous ça pourrait être de
vous j'ai connu toutes les formes de
déchéance y compris le succès s'avoue
très bien ça vous caractérise très bien
et vous vous avez dit en revanche les
honneurs je les méprise mais je ne
déteste pas forcément ce que je méprise
je trouve que c'est ces deux phrases
définissent à la perfection je pense
qu'une bonne façon de se débarrasser les
zellers et les avoir oui on y pense moi
que si on les apprend alors vous êtes
écrivain il ya un livre qui s'appelle
qui est là qui s'appelle le rapport
gabriel donc on va parler tout à l'heure
voilà je montre à la caméra comme on
fait la td michel noir il le fait bien
donc écrivain journaliste
si enfin c'est pas aussi important c'est
pas aussi important il fait dans l'autre
la phrase de gîtes qui disait en faire
que des citations de l'est dans le sens
il parle que par citation le journalisme
c'est ce qui sera moins intéressant
demain qu'aujourd'hui soit c'est vrai je
pense à huy pour ça que j'écris des
livres
oui
académicien l'académie sert à rester
beau hiver vous avez dit vous faites
aussi les grosses têtes de rtl orange et
alors vous jouer dans le prochain film
de jean luc godard et bien oui en
principe oui mais c'est il me semble que
le tournage est sans cesse reportée
avant ça devait déjà avoir lieu la
semaine dernière ça a été encore
reportée alors peut-être qu'on ne verra
pas dans cette rencontre
jean luc godard enfin franchement jean
d'ormesson faut le film et font profiter
bien non mais il vous a écrit ce bel
éloge de l'amour le film ah oui vous
avez écrit faisait pas reconnu ce site
youtube comment j'ai reçu une lettre et
g j'ai eu mal ou sa signature j'ai cru
que c'était une dame qui m'écrivait et
je lui ai répondu madame on verra ça
j'en ai il m'a téléphoné en me disant
c'est la première fois qu'on l'appelait
madame est là donc après quand vous avez
vous a rappelé donc et vous avez déclaré
on ne refuse pas un film d'un
financement alors juste pas un film bien
sûr
alors on a parlé un petit peu du rapport
gabriel en 86 donc bien avant d'écrire
le rapport gabriel vous aviez déclaré je
crois qu'il ya un dieu mais je n'en suis
pas sûr car il ne s'est jamais donné la
peine d'engager la conversation avec moi
mais ça a changé maintenant c'est fait
puisque dans ce livre dieu qui est en
colère qu'on veut que l'ange gabriel que
vous appelez caby 007 et qui lui donne
une mission c'est celle d'aller demander
aux hommes de s'expliquer sur les
désordres de l'histoire donc l'ange
gabriel va sur terre et post 123 on
compte jean d'ormesson est en train de
faire trempette dans la méditerranée et
il vous demande de raconter votre vie
pour écrire un rapport pour dieu c'est
ça voilà vingt dieu dieu aimait pourtant
dû est mécontent des hommes vous savez
il a été déjà d'autres fois il a été
mécontent au moment du déluge il a bien
essayé de détruire le monde avec les
luges qui était d'ailleurs partiale en
faveur des poissons comme vous savez si
bien racisme propose évidemment
et alors il avait abandonné à ce moment
là et maintenant il est encore plus
mécontent il faut que ça va plus mal je
trouve que n'est pas content et alors le
donner une dernière chance aux hommes et
et il envoie gabriel est déjà descendu
plusieurs fois qui a rencontré
ambras ans micka rencontrer la vierge
marie qui a rencontré mme en mai puis
cette fois là il tombe sur moi
génial d'un culot d'enfer
l'ange gabriel viens sur terre sur qui
tombe dedans me sont bien sûr qu'on
allait en faire en faire il ya un truc
excellent je vais pas évidemment je vais
pas citer tout le bouquin pas ce que
c'est on est pas là pour ça simplement
dire aux gens de le lire mes pages 356,6
un truc très rigolo qui résume bien le
bouquin parce que c'est quand même
vachement bien vous dites vous raconter
à l'engin une bonne partie du dernier
siècle s'est déroulée sous le signe des
jumeaux sanglant hitler et staline
ennemi mortel un liés entre eux par la
faiblesse et la faute des démocraties
libérales et là où c'est vraiment génial
le drame de mon époque c'est qu'il
fallait choisir entre eux non oui je
crois que c'est un résumé du xxème
siècle qui est extraordinaire dire que
tout le drame du 20e siècle
c'est tout les gens se sont crus obligés
d'être obligé de choisir entre hitler et
staline alors c'était la même chose
évidemment il fallait choisir entre eux
est évidemment s'est retrouvé dans le
même temps que staline et je crois qu'il
fallait se retrouver dans un staline
n'avait pas le choix il ya la peste et
le choléra et il faut choisir entre eux
et quelquefois on ne peut pas être
neutre en tous les cas c'est une fois
qu'ils traînent l'inscription bien sûr
c'est une belle description du 20e
siècle
vous parlez du pouvoir vous dire je n'ai
pas aimé le pouvoir car sa prétention me
fait rire je trouve que d'exercer le
pouvoir
j'aime pas beaucoup recevoir des ordres
oui mais je n'aime pas beaucoup non plus
en donner donc il vaut mieux que je
m'abstienne de ce genre d'activités mais
j'ai été j'ai été j'ai dirigé un journal
un journal de l'amc particulier parce
qu'on ne donne pas vraiment dedans mais
j'aime pas beaucoup les formes de
pouvoir c'est vrai j'aime pas le subir
et je n'aime pas beaucoup l'exercer pas
l'éloge vous savez
il faut bien qu'ils aient des gens qui
exercent le dax est né au cas je n'ai
pas du tout de dédain pour les les gens
qui exercent le pouvoir simplement moi
je ne suis pas je n'en suis pas friand
voilà alors en fait vous avez eu quand
même du pouvoir aussi parce qu'il y
avait une certaine culpabilité chez vous
de ne pas avoir su garder le château de
famille oui bien sûr
pourquoi est ce qu'on écrit des livres
parce qu'on a des chocs sentimentaux
alors ou bien pourquoi ils sont le credo
chanson pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait du
théâtre pourquoi est ce qu on fait du
cinéma pourquoi est ce qu on plaint
parce qu'on a eu choc sentimentaux lors
des chocs sentimentaux on les connaît
mais on peut avoir les différentes
espèces et perdre une maison parce qu'on
n'est pas capable de la garde et c'est
aussi un choc sentiment tout de suite
c'est à vous qui parle qu'elle est très
jolie saisir je vois bien vous êtes un
peu jaloux mais non vous avez vous avez
déclarez vous avez déclaré les premiers
les premiers livres on les écrit
toujours pour plaire aux filles
oui un charisme et au nom non d'imiter
zazie c'est une remarque je sais pas
comment je vais vous déjà vu c'est pas
bien montherlant qui a dit il ya l'amour
il allait vivre il n'y a rien donc voilà
oui c'est vrai je crois que l amour les
livrer voilà ton pardon
moi je suis dans l'amour rime dans le
rien on saisit vous ne trouvez pas
craquant jean d'ormesson parce que
l'esprit est ce qu'il ya de plus
séduisant fac je veux dire un truc quand
même il a déclaré une de mes plus
grandes passions étaient pour une femme
de 15 ans mon aîné
aujourd'hui avec des femmes de 15 ans de
plus c'est un peu difficile car en effet
mais rêve de vous rencontrer vraiment
très jolie veuve
vous savez le le coup le plus classique
qu'on me fait ces jouets arrivée les
jeunes filles ravissantes qui ont fait
un délicat c'est un livre est la phrase
classique était ma mère a tellement
d'admiration pour douala puis ça a
changé il ya quelques temps et c'est ma
grand-mère et l'eau doit jeter chez
gallimard raconte cette histoire et à ce
moment là y'a une stagiaire qui entre
ravissante charmant et je vous assure qu
elle a dit je crois que vous êtes un ami
devant le gardien vous avez des gares et
les temps à bord les corps vous avez si
j'avais dît si vous faites beaucoup de
citations
ah ben moi c'est une autre autre que ce
soit quand je vous cite attendait si la
mettait une femme j'aurais aimé mener
les hommes en bourrique
vous auriez été terrible saisonniers et
une femme adorait ça le pense pas j'ai
beau dire je suis très favorable aux
femmes oui vous emmener en bourrique les
femmes oui comment que je vous croyais
comment crois pas vous avez été un
bourreau des coeurs si vous saviez si
seulement je vous racontais un mois
si le ciel vous racontez nous votre pire
histoire d'amour alors ma pire histoire
d'âme le pire là plus que vous la
raconter tout de suite
un jour je suis invitée avec greta garbo
on est trop à table et me gêne beaucoup
quant à darbo et du prix d'une espèce de
folie je me met à chantonner le pinphone
cobb smith schlumberger est ce que ça
dit quelque chose je suis des pieds à la
tête
oui et c'est la chanson de l'ange bleu
ouais je sais comment la mélodie voilà
un an pile à vous voulez vous faire
chanter ça au plus bas à neuchâtel
je chante s'arrête à gogo l amour est à
vous est comme on assiste quand on fait
des gaffes et j'ai dit j'ai tellement
aimé l'ange bleu derrière j'ai dit je
vous êtes tellement admirée dans l'ange
bleu elle se retourne vers moi et me dit
je vois que vous me prenez pour marlene
dietrich plus tard je dîne à côté de
maman dit vraiment on s'entend bien on
s'entend vraiment bien et elle me dit
même ce qui est assez rare elle me dit
venez me voir
j'habite avenue montaigne je crois
qu'elle habitait vraiment un menteur et
je lui dis je vais vous raconter une
histoire tordantes
je lui raconte cette histoire elle m'a
tourné le dos elle m'a plu
donc pas de chance avec la maintenant on
arrive à on arrive à l'âge objets nous
en parler parce que je sais bien qu'on a
beaucoup parlé mais enfin quand même je
voudrais que vous en parlez de courant
donc ça tombe un jour je sais pas vous
regarder je regarde tous 357
qu'est-ce qui viennent qu'est ce qui dit
d'ormesson pas 65 ans voilà donc jean
d'ormesson prendre un petit déjeuner
avec françois mitterrand
mais un jour de la passation de pouvoir
se mettre le 17 mai 95 sapiac il papote
tous les deux comme ça gentiment il
parle de la sphère bousquet et
mitterrand lui dit cette phrase qui a
fait dont on parle depuis la sortie de
vie malheureusement par on a parlé un
peu trop de ça c'est pour ça qu avant
j'ai voulu quand même dire que il veut
autre chose dans le livre et mitterrand
dit à jean d'ormesson dont vous
constatez là pendant d'affaires bousquet
l'influencent puissante et nocive du
lobby juif en france voilà alors après
de gaulle qui avait dit que les juifs
étaient un peuple sûr de lui et
dominateur bissonnette ça il va un
dessin de steam dans l'express qui est
extraordinaire où il y avait un type qui
est derrière des barbelés dans un camp
de concentration il y avait il avait
remis la france était une violence et il
y avait ça et là donc françois
mitterrand dit ça on ne peut pas penser
que vous auriez écrit ça si ce n'était
pas vrai parce que de toute façon
personne ne pense plus que les femmes
non d'autant plus personne ne pense que
tout il l'a dit à plusieurs faire ça
voilà attendu c'est la même chose en
plus qui l'avait eu un procès que l'on
m'a fait on m'a dit qu'il fallait pas le
répéter
oui pas vous pas comme ça pas maintenant
ouais et alors évidemment moins moche et
mon droit le plus strict sur tous qui
m'avez pas du tout demandé le secret
alors je ne vous connaissent en même
temps c'était le répéter quand même
vous savez j'ai même cru de bonne foi
qu'il me l'avait dit pour que je le
répète je ne crois plus maintenant je
pense que quand on lui parlait de
bousquet celle l'exaspéraient et que
younès et il y avait de quoi est il a
laissé échapper sa main alors un certain
nombre de réactions il est roger hanin
qui a dit que j'étais un crétin ridicule
oui qu'il a piqué en communauté
française que pas très partagées non
plus même en france le giro cad il n'a
pu se retenir de faire dans sa culotte
oui pas très sympa non plus jack lang
plus violents il a dit on utilise
parfois l'autre pour exprimer ses
propres sentiments
la serbe
c'est assez il ya aussi jean daniel le
patron du nouvel obs qui a dit
d'ailleurs françois mitterrand lui avait
dit à jean daniel vous me corrigez si je
me trompe
tout s'y passe en somme comme si ce
lobby d'antan par exister vraiment donc
quasiment ou jean daniel qui va
soupçonner d'être de droite jacques
attali fourbe aussi qui a dit plusieurs
interlocuteurs m'ont rapporté ce type de
propos cela explique mes distances avec
les terrans alors qu'en fait il a pris
ses distances pour partir à la berd
vous savez j'ai été d'une discrétion
exquise bonne façon de parler second
match 357 parce que avant avant de danse
rit cette formule je n'en parle pas dans
le ive
mitterrand avait passé en revue avec moi
comme spectateurs muets le personnel
politique est alors il avait été surtout
sauvage sauvage avec les gens de son
bord et moi vous me connaissez très
courtois très bien élevé je lui disais
vous savez ce mon côté sont pas fort non
plus oui oui mais tu es sur le crétin
mais les miens
commencez à bien le fun et ring alors si
j'étais allé à la télévision ou à la
radio
et si j'avais dit voilà ce qui m'a dit
de untel untel je le dis à jamais mais
vous savez paris aurait sauté alors
voyez j'ai été très très modéré
jean-christophe mitterrand lui
effectivement il a alors lui il a
approuvé son père jean christophe
mitterrand fils de courses a rappelé la
mois non il a dit quand le monde a titré
mitterrand et l'antisémitisme
il y le monde fait partie de ces caisses
de résonance de certains monde pourquoi
pas d'un certain lobby juif donc le fils
de mitterrand vous ce que vous dites
c'est que personne n'a mis en doute vos
propos de toute façon personne ne met
pas en doute
[Musique]
d'ormesson mélanésiens
si jean d'ormesson jeu 10 ans dans le
sens une connerie le comte jean bruneau
vladimir françois de paule lefebvre
d'ormesson
[Musique]
génial jean d'ormesson vous voulez
toujours dans votre vieux coupé mercedes
oui lanvin fait toujours pour vous
spécialement son eau de lanvin oui voilà
c'est toujours dans le sang et puis je
suis à jean d'ormesson j'adore john
d'ormesson
je le dis franchement et tout de suite
vous incarnez pour moi une espèce de
france est en voie de disparition
malheureusement je crains est moi-même
bientôt envoie dise pas maintenant
parler pas de malheur non non non j'ai
connu toutes les formes de déchéance y
compris le succès c'est pas une belle
phrase les honneurs je les méprise mais
je ne déteste pas forcément ce que je
méprise
voilà c'est du jean d'ormesson c'est un
peu comme la place ya une phrase pas de
qui elle est tout avoir pour pouvoir
tout maîtriser ces kiss et barrès péguy
ou un truc comme ça non barèche barrès
alors publié mais c'est comment on fait
un ou publié chez robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle voilier
commandant ce mets m besson
avec c'est bien à cela c'est la version
chic sa version meubles bien alors
entrer dans la danse ça vient d'une
chanson entrer dans la danse voyez
comment danse chante et danse et
embrassez qui vous voudrez un cd cette
espèce de gaieté déjà tout de suite dès
le titre est s de fraîcheur alors vous
vous refusez une époque où tout le monde
est dans l'accablement houellebecq tient
dans la une époque où le bonheur est mal
vu vous refusez tout ça mais jérémiades
vous refusez écoutez je pense que si
j'occupe une place peut-être ta part en
train c'est pas dû à mon talent mais
peut-être parce que j'essaye de donner
un peu de bonheur aux gens qui me voient
là alors on sait bien que on sait bien
que la vie n'est pas gay tous les jours
je crois que puisque vous avez la bonté
de citer des phrases de moi je crois que
j'ai dit quelque part que la vie était
une fête en larmes et ce livre là aussi
c'est une fête en larmes quand dans les
bouquins on sent que vous amusez
beaucoup avaient peint des personnages à
raconter des destins imaginer des
intrigues on sent un vrai plaisir
d'écriture est au centre du dispositif
votre obsession pour le temps finalement
c'est un peu le personnage qui revient
dans tous vos livres
d'abord est-ce que c'est un plaisir
d'écrire je dirais que c'est très
difficile
ouais je dirais que c'est à la fois un
bonheur et une souffrance
il ya des pages que j'ai recommencé 18
fois ah oui oui vous êtes très bien
aussi
et oui c'est vrai je crois que ce qui
est le plus difficile c'est de donner
l'impression de facilité est alors sur
l'autre
vous avez absolument raison je pense que
le personnage principal livre c'est le
temps lui c'est le temps qui passe et
qui m'a toujours un peu obsédé comme ça
va pas le seul gérer un prédécesseur qui
s'appelait proust que c'est écoutait
beaucoup aussi
est ce que c'est le temps qui passe ou
nous qui passons peut-être que le temps
est immobile et c'est nous qui passons
oui n'ont pas le temps malade mais nous
nous en allons d'ailleurs vous avez
changé de coiffure
alors que vous en penser les gens
pendant deux choses sérieuses
un couple est aussi vrai succès ce truc
là on se ment la clim la télé par
exemple ça fait moins jean pierre
foucault à qui ai-je fait qu'ils veulent
alors vous mêlez très bien la grande et
la petite histoire faisait site créé un
roman total ce que tu une ambition tout
à fait louable et très moderne en même
temps vous savez il ya un film que nous
avons vu qu'ils s'appellent la comtesse
aux pieds nus
ouais alors au début il ya havas gagne
notamment bossi et puis à un très beau
gars qui est là et il revoit tout ce qui
s'est passé alors le lu le livre en un
mot ce serait passe en trois heures dans
un cimetière et à propos de tous les
gens qui passent en même temps on part
en chine en amérique du sud en inde et
le siècle entier voilà ça commence par
un enterrement on enterre romain qu'on
pourrait résumer en disant qu'il vivait
avec talent c'est un ami du narrateur
qui est le grand ordonnateur de ses
funérailles et une amitié finalement
comme celle qui lie deux personnes qui
ont aimé la même femme puisque tous les
deux le mar acteur et celui commentaire
oui mais marina des belles séances à
patmos je vais vous dire ce livre est
aussi c'est aussi une histoire d'amour
alors j'avais écrit jadis à un livre qui
s'appelle vent du soir où il y avait
quatre soeurs et là il y a permis de
faire une mère et une fille main et
alors autant de cette merde cette fille
on ya des hommes qui tourne alors à la
mer c'est maigre opinions qu'on appelle
la reine margot donc est une
collectionneuse de marie damman et
parler ses amants elle a eu lucky
luciano le chef de la mafia new yorkaise
et c'est lui qui a organisé en partie le
débarquement américain en sicile du fond
de sa prison et ses d aventure
formidable et alors le piano a tué
naturellement comme cocoon ça se passe
il a tué son prédécesseur mais son
prédécesseur était italien aussi et pour
le tuer
on disait les ceux qui voulaient le tuer
luciano se disait c'est pas possible de
prendre des gangsters italien parce
qu'il connaît tous les cancers
mais on a pensé aux gangsters juifs qui
ne connaissaient pas mais alors il ya
une autre difficulté c'est que le
meurtre avait été fixée incendie
parce que le samedi les gens étaient en
week end et la gare des témoins sérieux
mais les gangsters juifs au lit le jaune
le sabbat sans rien à faire pointu par
le jour du shabbat
alors on a dû changer la date on l'a
fait à mercredi ça s'est bien passé
la fille c'est marina dont qui a été
aimée effectivement à la fois par le
narrateur et par romain celui
commentaire ja.b cyr donc un musulman
qui fait la guerre dans la wehrmacht et
dont hitler empreinte larmes pour
suicider alors là tout est vrai aussi
il clair c'est vraiment suicidé avec un
valter 7,65 je crois alors vous dire que
béchir l'ouest c'est bon là peut-être
qu'un tout petit coup de pouce alors
tout le xxème siècle y passent un à
travers des souvenirs croiser des
différents personnages
vous m'avez dit dans tout le monde en
parle finalement le 20e siècle a eu à
choisir vous souvenez de ça entre deux
tragédies entre deux monstres le nazisme
et le stalinisme
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement s'en
était débarrassé est ce qu'aujourd'hui à
l'aube du xxième siècle on voit pas
arriver encore un totalitarisme c'est
non pas encore une fois le fait d'être
musulman mais le fait d'être
fondamentalistes et le fait d'élire bien
sûr je pense que vous savez le 11
septembre il ya quelque chose qui s'est
terminée et quelque chose qui a commencé
et nous ne savons pas exactement quoi
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya tout un peu
l'histoire qui est tombée en arrière je
pense que je dis c'est pas si tu vois le
risque est terminée on sait ce qui est
terminée mais c'est comme c'est comme la
déclaration de guerre de 14
c'est comme pearl harbour c'est comme la
chute du mur de berlin il ya un monde
nouveau qui commence lundi un mot
lacuzon vrai c'est que je suis ardemment
contre le terrorisme intégriste et je ne
mélange pas l'islam et le terrorisme
sont heureux de l'entendre dire c'est ce
canadien
déjà survenus vendredi entre la vie en
commençant cette émission tout à l'heure
avec ma fille et jamel est la pire chose
qu'on pourrait faire c'est de jeter
l'islam dans les bras du fondamentalisme
il faut faire le contraire voilà il faut
isoler les terroristes et les toros peut
venir de partout
vous savez que il ya eu un terroriste
qui s'appelait ah beh oui abbas georges
habache le fph était chrétien alors il
faut isoler les terroristes et tâcher de
regagner tout tout tout tout tout ceux
qui sont contre tout effort mais il
faudrait pas on peut dire la télévision
il faudrait pas qu'en france ce soit le
début d'un racisme anti arabe parce que
encore une fois ça serait ce qui pourra
l'être
dieu nous en garde je te jure ce qui me
fait le plus mal au coeur et qui m'a le
plus mois touché ce qui me fait le plus
peur pour l'avenir c'est l'amalgamé
qu'on risque de faire dans les rues je
sais que que ça va que l'enfer commence
pour nous vraiment j'ai ce sentiment là
j'ai peur pour ma petite soeur c'est
pour ça que jean d'ormesson dis ça mais
c'est le défi la démocratie la
démocratie ne peut pas employer elle
même les méthodes qu'elle condamne
absolument spa et donc il faut que la
démocratie soit à la fois forte et
respectueuse des autres
alors vous êtes académicien français oui
alors évidemment je vous faire une
interview proust express c'est ce que
tout le monde croit que c'est une
interview de bernard pivot mais en fait
c'est le questionnaire de proust
simplement je vais vous demander c'est
très important de répondre en faisant
des fautes de français comme vous et
académicien sur des fautes de français
au bois sans rien n'est plus facile sera
par exemple si je vous dis vous fait
couper les cheveux tous les combien vous
me répondez je vais au coiffeur une fois
par mois d'accord d'accord coiffeur une
fois le mois on ne bouge pas pendant le
dîner
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
bien vous êtes prêts toujours très bien
alors quel est pour vous le comble
drenthe bien fait quel est pour vous le
comble de la misère le compte de la
misère oui alors c'est les fautes et les
fours pour l'été je je je je je qu'aussi
bien ouais je crois aussi bien mais
voulait souffler si vous voulez aider
moi mais je suis je vous parlais très
très bien alors le compte de la misère
était que allez-y c'était que et puis là
il va vous aider je vois bien qu'il fait
un effort quotidien alors le compte de
la lisère le compte de la misère c'est
de sasp et et que ça serait que bg sa
mère vous êtes s'arrêter que baiser sa
mère de jean d'ormesson votre idéal de
bonheur terrestre mais reprendre ça
serait démarrer un roman démarrer un
faux bond la faute pour laquelle vous
avez le plus d'indulgence
les gens qui causent pas bien votre
qualité préféré chez l'homme
deux pas ces camps et sentais mieux ce
serait là lucas l'académie je pense
qu'il devrait rentrer rémy ce sera un
exemple bien sûr alors il faut pas salir
en rouge
non voilà votre qualité préféré chez la
femme l'unige hocini misogynie me parle
je visais émises par exemple à quelques
préfets reja femmes c'est camus ce qui
me plaisent bien
c'est dieu pour vous de faire des fautes
à vichy du principal défaut facile ça
cette cause est tellement bien ce que
vous détestez par dessus tout la musique
qu'il faudra la rue le don de la nature
que vous aimeriez avoir
la rapidité par exemple
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi c'est tellement non
j'aimerais bien c'est très bien
j'aimerais j'aimerais j'aimerais être
comme moi mon âge
ainsi jean d'ormesson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand nos sens
alors
je n'en voulais pas qu'ils voulaient
battre apple ajoute non sans est désolé
il peut pas m'embrasser sur la bouche
parce qu'il est académicien
enfin je peux vous remplacer alors j'ai
reçu un mail après votre dernier passage
dans l'émission un mail de arnaud
salomon qui a 25 ans et qui habite à
lille et qui dit juste pour dire qu'en
voyant jean d'ormesson
ça donne vraiment envie de devenir
académicien sauce âgées c'est
sincèrement alors subi un livre qui
voulait appeler adieu donc voilà en fait
seul hésité entre adieu les carottes
sont cuites il va faire est dans le sac
ou et voilà le travail
et voilà le travail c'est pas mal et
finalement donc ça s'appelle c'était
bien et c'est chez gallimard mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]
voilà c'était bien alors c'est pas un
roman c'est pas des mémoires c'est pas
un essai c'est quoi un truc assez un
truc tamassa vous auriez dû le marquer à
la place pour tresser le reste un truc
simple c'est parce que sinon c'est pas
les mémoires non bah non c'est pas un
effet pas ce qu'on me dit de quoi parlez
vous j'avais très peur que vous me
disiez de quoi parlez vous annoncer très
compliqué c'est elle fait une espèce de
d'état des lieux
voilà autant dire qu'on va dire ça mais
bon comment comment ça va voilà comment
ça va alors pendant que j'explique
comment ça va j'explique aussi aux
lecteurs comment lui va voilà à peu près
voilà alors le pitch finalement c'est
votre vie le pitch à l'académie se voit
je compte sur vous pour que le mot pitt
se rendre dans le dictionnaire en trois
phases
alors je n'ai pas encore fait entre à
l'académie je les fais entrer chez
gallimard et je leur ai dit je vais vous
expliquer le pitch le pic et personne
chez gallimard vous savez ce que vous
voulez bien le faire alors j'ai dit mais
comment vous n'écoutez pas ardisson lui
enfin
et à l'intention de ceux qui font les
études je leur ai même dit par exemple
quel est le pitch de faire bien le pitch
de fait c'est une dame est amoureuse de
son beau fils malheureusement le beau
fils est victime d'un accident la
circulation voilà voilà le pitch est
fait c'est quoi le ps de la recherche
le pitch puis à cherche c'est un petit
gars on attend le baiser de sa mère de
l'asseoir dans la nuit et comme on ne
vient pas suffisamment à son gré il va
dans les bals pour se consoler voilà
voilà le pitch de la recherche alors le
pizzo votre bouquin 10 ans et ma vie
bilan globalement très positif
est ce que je peux apporter une toute
petite armée molle ou ce qui est positif
ce n'est pas ma vie
c'est là aussi c'est la vie ma vie elle
aurait pu être mieux
je serai minou et je serai gide je serai
aragon je serai extrêmement satisfaits
n'étant pas un bond récent pas
chateaubriand n'étant pas gide
je suis un peu mélancolique mais ce qui
est bien c'est la vie c'est la vie
en tous les cas ça donne l'occasion
d'être avec vous c'était bien alors en
tous les cas vous n'avez jamais eu
besoin de psy voix non
vous avez survécu à la psychanalyse au
nouveau roman vous avez survécu à jean
paul sartre ah ça c'est pas mal quand
même non ben oui il y en a qui ont
laissé des plumes
alors il ya une autre façon de pitch est
votre livre j'en sais il ya deux grandes
interrogations dans la vie l'une au
début c'est que faire et l'autre c'est à
la fin qu'ai-je fait c'est une façon de
le raconter aussi
alors écoutez je vois qui est ici il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont 20 ans et si je
vous dois quelque chose thierry et je
vous dois beaucoup
c'est que probablement vous m'avez
fournit des lecteurs plus jeune que ce
que jamais
quand j'écrivais au priseur de dieu
j'avais sûrement des lecteurs que j'aime
beaucoup mais qui était sûrement
beaucoup plus âgés et peut-être que les
gens qui glissent maintenant sont un peu
plus jeunes grâce en partie à eybens
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai dans ce qu'il
faut mais apporte sans faire de fausse
modestie
c'est vrai que cette émission est
beaucoup regardé par les jeunes et
qu'elle est qu'elle vend des livres et
alors quand j'avais 20 ans vous savez eh
bien je trouvais ça très dur
vraiment je trouvais ça très dur et
pourtant j'avais des avantages énormes à
20 ans j'étais fonctionnaire
j'étais entré à l'école normale j'étais
payé ma carrière et s était engagé au
bon
en plus quand j'avais 20 ans je crois
que le taux de chômage était de 0,4 pour
cent
c'est à dire que ce qu'on voulait faire
on trouve et où il ya métier vous le
trouviez et bien malgré ça j'ai trouvé
ça très dual avoir 20 ans il y avait une
phrase célèbre de deux ans vous
connaissez je me permettrai à personne
de dire que 20 ans et le plus bel âge de
la vie
eh bien c'était vrai montant alors je
vous jure que je ne cherche pas à faire
la démagogie
ouais mais je trouve que les gens qui
ont 20 ans aujourd'hui ont vraiment
beaucoup de courage parce qu'ils sont
très dessin on mettrait est très très
confiants et moi je trouve ça épatant
alors votre précédent livre jean
s'appelait voyez comment danse et ça
commençait déjà autour du cercueil d'un
ami à c'est déjà un peu vous commenté
ray d'une certaine façon vous savez
c'est vrai et vous savez quelque fois on
me dit alors qu'est ce que tu penses de
ton livre et je dis je ne sais pas je
n'ai encore vu personne et c'est les
gens qui lisent les livres qui
m'apprennent et kim tout à coup c'est
vrai ce livre ci tourne quand même
beaucoup autour de 2,1 et l'envoie là
non cela n'est pas bon le nonce de ma
mort est très mature et oui mais enfin
bon moi excusez moi je suis si vous
faites ça pour qu'on vous il reste avec
nous et tu permets moi ces vols pulse et
valbonne enfin le livre précédent
s'était déjà l'enterrement et je sais
pas peut-être que quelques-uns d'entre
vous se souviennent d'un livre qui
s'appelait la douane le maire et je
mourrai à la première part alors
évidemment c'est un problème qui m'a un
peu fait pour conjurer le sort je suis
sur moi c'est peut-être aussi une
certaine
vous avez honte traitant j'apparais
beaucoup comme une espèce de champion un
peu benêt du bonheur je veux crétins qui
trouve que tout va bien
il ya aussi sûrement une grande
mélancolie dans et dans mes livres
depuis le début mai une mélancolie à ses
gains jeudi à tous les gens qui sont ici
profiter de jean d'ormesson parce
qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup des comme ça
moi j'en profite au maximum si je
pouvais l'avoir cinq fois par an entre
la barre d'abord merci thierry je
voudrais ajouter que profiter de moi
vous n'avez plus pour si longtemps et
ensuite étiré je voulais vous demander
ce que je pourrais avoir ici un rond de
serviette
oui mes pantoufles mais attendez parce
que quand j'arrive là évidemment j'ai
l'impression de mieux chez moi mes coups
talent dans cash non que vous voulez je
voulais remplacer baffie vous pouvez
bien alors le contenu du bouquin alors
il ya cette phrase vous vous dites
la vie c'est les livres les femmes et
les bains de mer et gaston gallimard lui
disaient les bars les femmes et alors
cessé il ya quand même un jour il répond
c'est pas tant ouais ouais c'est pas
tant les balmer bon vous voyez ce que
c'est sérieux pas seulement les bains de
mer au bond les courses en voiture
l'italie les îles grecques
les voyages
voilà je suis à 3 mademoiselle et non
voilà bon et puis les femmes
alors ça c'est bien parce que on m'a
souvent dit à la télévision pas de
tunnel non pas que tunnel sur les femmes
on n'en parle pas pour le mourinho n'en
parle pas alors et les livres alors on
peut en parler
on parle évidemment des thèmes qui sont
des thèmes or mais sonia come on come on
dira bientôt le privilège de la
naissance le sens de l'histoire vous
parler du big bang
c'est très très riche si les thèmes
souvent abordés mais cette fois c'est
vrai qu'il ya une petite mélancolie ya
quelque chose d'un petit peu comme ça
quoi
la fêlure dans crystal le thème de la
naissance je pensais que au fond bon
j'ai été élevé ou est-ce que j'ai été
élevé j'ai été levée dans un château
bah oui eh ben c'est mon trotskisme amoa
ya des gens qui ont un passé trente ce
qu'ils vont pas très bien pourquoi les
emmerder avec ça éternellement
et ben moi non plus on va pas m'emmerder
entendre été élevé dans un château a
tout à fait les trotskistes mis en
risque est chaude du château il en reste
quelque chose aussi
mais on essaie d'oublier tout ça voilà
dans le bilan ou fait finalement de la
vie d'une certaine façon j'en sais
comment s'est guère plus en partant
qu'en arrivant quoi un nom alors si
c'était à refaire votre vie si c'était à
refaire je ne leur ferai pas un non
franchement j'ai trouvé ça épatant j'ai
vraiment beaucoup aimé la vie et si un
bon génie ou un mauvais génie mme disait
voilà tu peux recommencer je crois pas
que je recommencerai évidemment
[Rires]
évidemment eliane attendent et méritent
et pire encore donc là mais c'est vite
quoi la même si ça aurait été possible
aussi d'amasser là mais c'est vite la
messe est dite or qu'est-ce que vous
changeriez si votre vie était à refaire
imaginons vous acceptiez de la refaire
vous changeriez quoi offrir les mêmes
les mêmes folies les mêmes terrains
rocheux cachait peut-être de rencontrer
un peu plus tôt façon vous avez survivre
à votre nom puisque vous allez rester
dans la postérité non la postérité
oui alors vous savez j'y crois plus aux
abords je pense que la postérité il
fasse est une idée de l'avenir
eh bien je crois que cette idée de
l'avenir appartient au passé
vous savez pourquoi un peu à cause de
vous un peu à cause de la télévision la
télévision est une formidable machine à
éclairer mais la télévision est aussi
une machine à oublier quand on ne passe
plus à la télévision les autres passent
et tout ça fait que on est balayé et
c'est très difficile je crois de se dire
que on restera dans la postérité avec
toute cette masse d'informations d'image
d'événements qui roule sur le monde
c'était facile autant de flaubert ou
jean brillon mais fera au fera des
émissions romain soir arte
moi je vous ferai les émissions hommage
vous promet peut-être du mal on dira qu
16 dollars voilà vous êtes très fort
c'est que vous avez j'arrive à faire ce
bouquin là sans parler de vous en fait
oui alors vous savez gérer gm va là il
ya une différence église homme politique
c'est que eux disent toujours nous
sommes transparents oui moi je ne suis
pas de france pas du tout non plus mais
à une époque où votre ami jean marie
rouart raconte ses coucheries à
montparnasse g c'est terrible d'ailleurs
oui alors ça vous a pas donné un petit
peu l'idée vous d'aller un peu plus loin
dans les confidences alors redit tout
moi je n'ai pas grand chose non mais
d'ailleurs quand on relit les articles
quand on relit les articles ont été
écrits sur vous on s'aperçoit vous êtes
toujours méfier terriblement des
journalistes parce que vous laissait
rien paraître
vous devez vous méfier des biographes
parce qu'une fois que vous serez plus là
les mecs ils vont fouiller dans vos
packs mais savoir eh bien c'est que tu
devais me faire re ah ouais l'idée qu'il
puisse y est roi et biographies mois et
qu'on cherche dans ma vie sam épouvante
gma ne craque pas trop de moi près la
même
même si vous vous détruisez toutes les
lettres par exemple de femme c'est une
supposition que vous avez reçu demandé à
ces femmes à qui vous en avez écrit
détruire le tour drôle du tout renvoie
lui tout mail avant vous faites un
hommage sur arte et c'est tout
d'accord alors jma il ya des choses
qu'on sait pas mais par exemple si je
suis très curieuse genre est ce que par
exemple ses orgasmes
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait l'amour
en costume d'académicien par exemple non
non jamais elles sont fort même mais
même j'aurais pu par exemple le faire
sans habits d'académiciens mais un
bicorne sur leur nom
est-ce que vous avez déjà pratiqué des
jeux érotiques avec l'épée gens à
[Applaudissements]
l'elysée
bonjour qui est peut-être bon secours
enfin vous expliquer sans arrêt que vous
êtes au bout du chemin gens nous on veut
pas le croire bien entendu on pense que
ce livre est destiné qu'à vous faire
aimer encore plus si c'est possible
puis qui aura après alors encore plein
d'autres 1 c'était bien c'était vraiment
bien c'était vraiment super bien mais
quand même pour conjurer le sort on va
passer à votre oraison funèbre est
patent voici dieudonné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
genre genre janot nous occuper jeannot
janon le réac
elle a déjà non la thrombine comme on
l'appelait étouffée dans son sommeil par
un glock terreux c'est une sommité
mais c'est aussi un père un grand père
et même n'auriez grand-père un que nous
pleurons ce soir consiste à dieu jamot
étouffé par tong l'air à présent je vais
demander à gilbert elle est le frère de
jaune ou un des deux venir nous parler
de cet ami de ce frère donc gilbert je
vais te demander de devenir ainsi berck
est un peu vieux lui aussi alors je me
mets ou si monsieur le curé mais bien
alors dans le micro les jobards alors
alors alors alors alors alors mon gâteau
je n'ai jamais su te dire que je t'aime
mais aujourd'hui 108 août qui arriverait
pauthe
j'ai envie de te tenir les jus oui
j'adore je t'aime tu vois tu aurais dû
mourir plus tôt pour me l'entendre dire
alors les 80 ans bombail 80 piges l'été
le tua caqueta péter commun on est avec
tout ce que tu t'es foutu dans la gueule
tout au long de sa vie se profile pas
non plus c'était quand même la moindre
des choses
enfin alors donc non je termine donc ni
alors donc seigneur jésus marie prévenu
georges est en soin de lui à et surtout
garde le prétoire pas de blaye n'en veut
plus pas de résurrection
merci gilbert bercy longwy les genevois
entendu les messages d'amour qui lui
envoyer
amour amour waouh
quand tu t'en part de nos coeurs comme
ça qui nous causent bien des
emmerdements
voilà une petite horizon fines herbes
que j'ai fait pour janot 1 jean
d'ormesson voilà cet exercice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci dont vous aurez tous ce soir
c'est pas le prendre comme ça je sais je
sais je vous avais je voudrais ajouter
un mot et bientôt d'une idole diallo
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
avec nous dieudonné parce qu après
l'oraison funèbre
il ya jugement dernier intervient
jugement dernier
jean d'ormesson 1 tu utilisé sa
notoriété pour séduire je crois que me
suis servi des femmes
ouais pour être connu ouais et ensuite
je me suis servi ce que j'étais connu
pour avoir des femmes à jean d'ormesson
as-tu consommé des substances
aphrodisiaques
hélas mise amant jean d'ormesson
as-tu pêcher en accomplissant l'acte
d'amour sans volonté de procréer c'est
ce qu'il faut dire la vérité
bah au jugement dernier oui jean
d'ormesson
as-tu pêcher à la mouche à la bouche
jean d'ormesson as tu envie d'une jeune
cousine oui secret défense jean
d'ormesson
as-tu plus durant son existence à la
communauté homosexuelle
grâce à dieu oui comment je me rappelle
que les y raconte on entre nous face à
chacun d'entre nous
alors je ne voulais pas ruiner d'un coup
tout le capital de sympathie que je me
suis attirée je ne suis pas homosexuel
mais évidemment j'ai beaucoup plus à les
homosexuels qui ont été les amis très
chers à moi que j'ai beaucoup aimé et
quelquefois j'ai été obligé de courir un
peu dans la salle de bar autour d'eux
autant de la cuisine s'est arrêté là
jean d'ormesson
as tu regardé tf1 le samedi soir
il m'est même arrivé le regarder
thalassa
il est arrivé le tout regarder jean
d'ormesson
as tu déjà eu envie de te suicider
je me suis toujours arrêter le sur cette
pente parce que je pense que le suicide
ratée est une chose très ridicule
jean d'ormesson as tu déjà cru que dieu
n'existait pas pire quelques fois je me
suis allé jusqu'à croire qu'il existait
jean d'ormesson as-tu commis le péché de
mensonges en répondant à ces questions
oui bien sûr justement t-il j'en appelle
à l'assistance
l'enfer ou le paradis parfait
[Musique]
aulas et j'allais tout maintenant ce
n'est plus la même de mourir des stylos
raisons ci-dessus ce dernier vous avez
si on vous avait demandé vous auriez
choisi le l'enfer ou le paradis
vous connaissez la réponse célèbre pour
pour le climat oui je préfère le paradis
mais pour la compagnie de l'enfer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jacques et jean d'ormesson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean d'ormesson mesdames messieurs
bonsoir un bisou un bisou bisou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous ces disques vert
c'est un homme que j'aime
nous aussi on aime bien sûr ça va ça va
bien heureux de vous voir dans ces mots
forme éblouissante
je n'ose même pas dire votre âge on peut
dire votre jeune fille sans eric chez
moi j'ai peur d'être le bon père de tout
le monde
vous êtes génial 80 ans
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce que je fais catherine
enfin vous dit du bien de moi
catherine barma me demande que vous
changer de place voilà oui là je la
place d'isabelle mergault qu'on m'a dit
de m'asseoir entre pierre et isabelle ce
n'est pas très dur de prendre ma place
[Musique]
genre je vais passer un bon été très bon
c est ce qu ont su prochain vous avez
passé un été brûlant
est-ce que savoir si je vais passer
l'hiver jean est ce qu'on supporte mieux
la canicule quand tu avais une mortelle
ah oui tiens le froid et le chaud ça
m'est complètement tigana n'y a pas de
problème ça va
alors voilà gens vous êtes de retour
parmi nous et j'en suis ravi parce que
ça vous fait un livre dit chez le
dernier
vous finissez toujours par revenir quand
même pourquoi oui certes pas se produire
sup écrire ses livres et s'il était un
peu à testament bilan et puis je fais
comme la castafiore je fais mes adieux
et puis revient vous it écrire c'est
difficile ne pas écrire c impossible
voilà un excédent voir venir et
divisible ne pas écrire est imposible
formulaire en très belle forme et vous
revenez en est ravi alors cette fois
vous publié chez robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle une fête en
larmes très beau livre c'est ce qu'on
appelle un oxymore laurent et voilà tu
prends la torre la force tranquille tu
vois ça fait gentiment larmes voilà
devant une nuit très clair voilà un
amour et bleu ingall molle un oxymore
demi molle c'est une épargnante
immensément alors le pitch whl faire le
pitch c'est un écrivain qui reçoit une
jeune journaliste qui vient à
l'interviewer elle a 20 ans elle sait
rien c'est un peu bécassine faut dire
les choses et lui évidemment ici à jour
il sait tout puisque c'est vous alors ce
rendez vous qui devait durer une heure
ou deux va durer pas moins de neuf
heures pause déjeuner comprise et le
vieil écrivain qu'elle vient interviewer
va lui raconter sa vie c'est à dire
votre vie romancée votre vie rêvée dans
l'esprit de ce que aragon appelé le
mentir vrai on sait jamais si c'est à
dire assez énervante c'est un peu potes
pour brouiller les pistes
cette fois brunel pis vous êtes fort on
sais pas moi même je ne sais plus je
raconte ma vie mais je lui invente même
temps il se trouve que l'écrivain en
question vous a connu la grand mère de
la jeune fille alors là c'est parti vous
parlez de votre enfance de votre famille
du château et il ya des choses
extraordinaires quand vous en avez parlé
de ce château 1 et beaucoup au plaisir
de dieu ça a commencé avec ça mais bon
alors vous dites nous étions
réactionnaire la vie était comme elle
était dans les siècles passés
l'avenir nous intéressait peu c'est une
vie de lenteur plus tourné finalement
effectivement vers le passé que vers
l'avenir et iec surtout que rien ne
change ouais ouais voilà et moi ce que
j'ai aimé c'est que les choses changent
ouais c'est vrai alors vous dit une
chose c'est qu'elle est peuvent vous
dites on était chrétien ont été
intimement persuadé que tous les hommes
étaient frères mais de là à croire
qu'ils étaient égaux c'était quand même
autre chose quoi il y avait un ordre des
choses d'ailleurs des choses et nous
étions au sommet voilà voilà
vous racontez vos amours une léa et une
mare idéal je vais en amérique je suis
professeur la mairie et je tombe sur une
jeune juive qui sort du ghetto de
varsovie et alors les a vécu là dedans a
échappé à la shoah est arrivé en
amérique à la suite d'aventurés
extraordinaires et je tombe amoureux
d'elle et malheureusement
je rencontre une autre jeune femme marie
et je découvre peu à peu que mari son
frère était non seulement collabos non
seulement vichyste mais a servi dans
l'armée allemande sous l'uniforme
allemand et a été fusillé à la
libération
alors bon vous voyez à à travers ma vie
a raconté le 20e siècle est un simple
épouvantable et à sept du pouvant table
des faits né cistre sinistre j'ai
calculé que il devait y avoir dans le
livre jeudi il va y avoir entre 100 et
200 millions de mort par violences
eh bien je crois qu'un à plutôt 300
millions avec la shoah et cote
concentration les goulags la chine le
soudan le pôle potes maintenant à
absolument c'est le siècle des
idéologies genre qualité bien sûr on va
vous raconter vos voyages
vous racontez vos premiers livres au
plaisir de dieu qui n'est plus de
modestie etc ce qui m'a toujours où il
vous dit d'ailleurs effectivement vous
avez pas de succès un jour écrivait même
un bouquin qui s'appelle au revoir et
merci
et puis vous savez ce que c'est on
retombe et j'ai fait un bouquin sur un
empire imaginaire peut donc l'étudier
c'était une espèce de canulars
universitaire qui était la gloire de
l'empiré et et ça faisait huit cents
pages je n'ai apporté chez grasset qui a
été épouvanté
car pas voulu publier j'ai apporté chez
gallimard et il a fait ça sans me
l'exemple et voilà voilà comment ça se
passe voilà alors votre bouquin vous
vous dites c'est un roman mais quand
votre intervieweuse page 235 vous
demande ce que vous êtes en train
d'écrire vous dites une espèce de machin
oui c'est un truc oui parce que il est
vrai que quand je commence le livre je
suis d'ici dans la conversation un
l'intervieweuse mais dans la réalité je
me disais
plus écrire des livres et puis au fur et
à mesure que je parle avec elle
eh ben mon livre est en train de se
faire et quand le quand la conversation
est finie et doit le livre fini aussi
alors vous verrez de l'interview dans ce
livre dit que pour vous l'interview est
un est un supplice parce que vous
refusez de parler de votre vie privée
volige je parle souvent de moi même mais
jamais de ma vie privée oui c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai qu'on sait pas en fait
moi je le sais parce que je vous connais
vous savez pas ce que vous savez tout
mais j'en parle très peu
j'ai beaucoup aimé michel vaujour les
silences de michelle bohin j'ai tourné
saipa de temps en parler de l'amour gens
très bien de mieux en mieux mais je
trouve que vous êtes vraiment à chaque
fois alors là pour le coup c'est pas la
france court encore après les femmes
c'est plus très bien pour vite l'amour
c'est ce qu'on a trouvé de mieux pour
rendre la vie supportable
bien sûr bien sûr de quoi est-ce qu'on
s'occupe d'autres regards des passants
de quoi est ce qu'on se dit très
séduisant à mais il est allé ce qu'on
pense qu'on va très bien et il a doublé
en plus non mais ça je m'en fous
ouais saisir le 8 la une des phrases
formidable dit au sujet de la vieillesse
vire ses seuls moyens ne pas être mort
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est ce que j'ai
fait alors vous parlez de la mort vous
dites la vie n'est belle que parce que
nous mourons sera supportable mourir il
a dit des photos et il est mortel s'est
passé il ya qu un truc dans votre
bouquin moi qui m'a fait rire c'est
vraiment j'adore ce bouquin mais quand
vous dites
tu sais film toi interview donc il dit à
la jeune fille qui l'interviewent qui
vient d'un magazine comme ça et il lui
dit je vous ennuie avec toutes mes
histoires et tout au nom monsieur
d'ormesson au nom vous m'ennuyer pas
vous êtes tellement intéressant ça
s'appelle voilà un signe fort
complémentaires
les questions les réponses tu as fait ça
je suis déçu mais fier d'être ici
alors voilà alors il ya deux types de
réactions par rapport au bouquin vous
avez vu il ya ceux qui disent y'en a
marre on n'en peut plus genre beigbeder
dans voici qui dit c'est la énième
compile d'ormesson
c'est vrai c'est un peu comme comme dave
c'est à dire que mais c'est faux vanina
il ne dit pas mais là vanina de
d'ormesson
c'est chateaubriand quoi c'est à dire
que l'on peut plus y à télérama aussi
qui dit jean d'ormesson ressasse ses
poncifs sur venise sur la chute du mur
de berlin c'est une paresseuse
dissertation de causeur monde donc ça
c'est ça c'est fait c'est fait c'est
réglé et puis on en parlera aux plus
grands parcs gadget il n'y a pas pire
gadgets ja ja eysines dans l'ope si on
te veine dans le point il ya le
nourricier alors là il vous trouve
épatant délicieux car les gens ne se
lasse pas de vous finalement qu'est-ce
qui vous rend tellement sympathique
c'est vos yeux c'est quoi il est
complètement séduisant et les a jamais
tout sortant vous il est il est
intelligent il est lui freddy les îles
et ravissant cet homme est ravissant
totalement de la corde
je les adore voilà maintenant il est
avec lui moi demain il me demande en
mariage
eh ben
j'arrêtais mois vous pouvez jeter
témoins de jéhovah je m'aperçois gens
vous êtes une une star de l'académie
donc on va vous faire une interview star
academy français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va comparer un petit peu la
star ac et et l'académie à la star
academy et l'académie française est ce
qui est de la meuf à la kdf la mort hier
la main son cours c'est même moi qui l'a
fait entrer c'était dur sonar un dur ce
n'est qu'à se rappeler bien c'est ce
soir qui est fait entre m la première
femme à laquelle me vous vous rappelez
qu'il y avait toute la presse pas
seulement parisienne mais française et
mondiale et à la fin on m'a demandé
alors qu'est ce qui a changé à
l'académie et j'ai répondu
maintenant il y aura deux toilettes sur
le mur a écrit messieurs et sur l'autre
marguerite yourcenar et depuis j'ai vu
d'autres
il ya eu ce midi avec madame de
robotique est une merveille bien
florence delay il ya notre secrétaire
perpétuel de la meuf
c'est là là là tu vois les packs des
tons là la star ac et l'académie
française c'est la même chose est ce
qu'il ya des couples qui se sont formés
à l'académie française sur y en avoir
mais défaire recevrez donc sérieux bien
sûr nous ne devons nous pas des détails
est ce que l académie française comme la
star ac vous pouvez perdre votre place à
tout moment à nos impôts c'est un an
pour toujours impossible ça on ne peut
pas juste mais il ya des angles ils
peuvent pas être viré lui sa vie il ya
des embrouilles entre académiciens des
embrouilles
mais oui souvent ils se détestent ouais
d'abord ils sont tous habillés pareil
ouais on veut recoller par choix est-ce
que ça parle beaucoup dans le dos des
autres comme la star ac oui ces gens
c'est loin vous avez une salle de sport
bah non non
salle csa non non on pourrait on
pourrait s qu'il ya beaucoup de
prétendants et peu d'élus oui bah oui
tout le monde
ouais tout le monde veut y aller tout le
monde tous nos filiales et c'est qu'ils
ont reçus nous sommes 40 aille a pas de
prochain y'a pas trop ça y'a pas de ton
chien qui meurt il faut atteindre cannes
à ce qu'on ne souhaite pas mais il en
mourra sûrement très vite il en meurt
trois
est-ce qu'ils avaient un prof de diction
à l'académie française moi je veux vous
donner des cours de diction c'est l'âge
alors est-ce que vous pouvez vous
exclure les uns les autres en votant non
alors on peut exclure on peut exclure
les candidats ouais mais où va cogner
c'est fini alors est-ce que c'est comme
à la star ac il ya toujours un noir un
conte un belge une big moe une douche et
un nul pour que le monde entier puisse
se reconnaître non alors à courre
sûrement un belge à la une bimbo à wigan
est une des oui oui un nul
est-ce que c'est comme à la star
actuellement nous oublié au bout de deux
ans à l'académie française non non non
pas du tout non ça ne t'a dure longtemps
puisqu'on victimes mortelles ça va
immortel on est tranquille je viens par
crois que vous êtes vraiment immortel
non mais vous savez la définition
c'était ont été mortels pour la durée de
notre vie et après on se change en
fauteuil
jean d'ormesson
dans l'art c'est publié chez envers la
forme la meilleure et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu